[Music]
hend Andrews welcome to how the light
gets s happy to be here let's get right
into it you've called the enlightenment
white identity politics what did you
mean by that so the idea that knowledge
kind of starts in 17 century 18 century
Europe and it spreads out across the
rest of the world wean that simply is
little more than propaganda I in the
16th century the only part of the world
in a dark age was probably Europe right
and so these ideas of science and reason
and everything really you can Trace that
back to Africa Asia Middle East etc etc
and certainly something happens in
Europe in that period but the idea the
rest of the world was in was in the dark
Asian then it was Europe that kind of
saves the world it's what a nonsense it
is it really is this idea that knowledge
is white and that's why I call it white
identity politics what about the sort of
content of Enlightenment thinking
there's often uh now a claim that a lot
of U Enlightenment thinkers people like
David Hume John log Emanuel K were
actually racists and and so we shouldn't
really be taking them as seriously as
perhaps we have so far what's your take
on I mean there's no doubt that the key
Enlightenment thinkers were racist and
not just a little bit racist like just
obviously odiously racist I mean the
best example is Emanuel Kent who is kind
of given as a person of universal human
rights and all these but I mean he would
tell you he's a racist a big chunk of
his work is what he called moral
geography which is where he separated
the world into different regions based
on intelligence and Africa is the the
the least most backwards Europe is the
is the most enlightened in fact he says
it's the the white race that has all the
talent and this is how we know we're
rational and there's been all these
crazy defenses of K saying well you can
separate his racism from his philosophy
but he didn't he makes it very clear
that his moral geography and his moral
philosophy are the same thing and the
reason that he can tell you about
Universal human rights is because he is
white and because he is rational the
whole thing is is a racist project even
if K himself thought that his thought
was sort of holistic in this way that
you know his views on race fed into his
views on moral philosophy is it possible
for us to extract as it were some core
ideas from his philosophy and sort of
[Music]
decolonialization is structurally racist
right the idea there is one there is
this thing of rationality the idea you
can separate the Mind from the body and
there is this rational human from the
very beginning that is based on the idea
of whiteness that white people are less
biological white people are more
rational white people like an evolved
part of the species and then what you
get is this Universal rights um where
the universal rights are white supremacy
so think about the UN which Emanuel Kent
is very influential in the idea the
right to life is something which is for
everybody but the right to Prosperity is
not guaranteed and why is it not
guaranteed is because the colonial
violence which makes Kent possible that
creates this world where white people
are at the top and black people at the
bottom everybody else is in between that
is essentially defended by this
framework of Human Rights where we just
guarantee the right to life life we
don't guarantee the right to reparations
or the right to Prosperity the right to
anything else and it freezes everybody
in their state of nature uh what what if
someone said well isn't there really any
kind of emancipatory message in cans for
example his definition of the
Enlightenment which is a kind of form of
autonomy this move from following the
rules of another to following one's own
rules relying on one's own Reason Not
the sort of guidance of someone else
isn't that a a kind of emancipatory
message we can take out of that cont
text and apply to everyone I mean it
sounds nice in theory right but actually
let's look at the practice so what was
the promise of the Enlightenment is when
you don't have uh religious Authority or
when you don't have and you have moral
Authority through science or whatever
through through evidence Etc this is
supposed to make things Freer right but
actually let's take slavery or
colonialism um when you move away from
the religious justification we actually
getting worse justification with a
scientific justification and in fact
Emanuel Kent Justified slavery for
decades right said it was perfectly fine
because you had evidence that people
were inhuman and so I think the the TR
record of this shows us very clearly
that it's supposed to give us Li
Liberation but actually it doesn't give
that at all and in fact often makes it
worse and I think today the perfect
example is the UN that has these
Universal human rights it's the body
that's supposed to look after the world
right but won't talk about racism well
if you actually look at the world the
poorest parts of the world are black the
richest parts of the world white there
is a hierarchy in between whiteness is
clearly the most important indicator in
terms of global life Chang
and the UN never talks about it like
never ever ever talks about just talks
in this kind of vague idea about rights
the right to life the right to play all
these those kind of right and that comes
from can it's not an it's not an
accident that framework justifies the
racial exploitation which it is built on
because you don't get the enlightenment
without the preceding two three
centuries of of colonial
violence what about ancient Greek
philosophy right so you know it
coexisted with slavery Aristotle also
offers a justification for for slavery
should we cancel Aristotle as a wereare
you know are the people who still find
sort of fruitful ideas in his work even
though they might see slavery as a kind
of unquestionable evil are are those
people misguided are they doing
something wrong no I mean I think it's
not necessarily about canceling
Aristotle why even canceling K I mean
look this read K if you want I don't
think it's that useful I'm not saying
don't read it I read it if you want but
it is about saying well actually what
there are limited utility in these
things and there are limited utility
even in Aristotle going back to and at
one piece of it and saying well let's
just use that it's not really how it
works you have to look at the the
grander framework and if you look at
something like the enlightenment without
a doubt it is only possible because of
colonial violence that so even the idea
that white people are super so takes
take K and not just K cuz Hume luck
rouso they all agreed that white people
were Superior well 200 years earlier to
that that they couldn't even have
conceived of that because white people
clearly weren't Superior they were
clearly actually relatively backward
right when they were more books in one
library in timbuk 2 than they were in
the whole of Europe right nobody would
have said yeah why why does he Superior
so there's this 200-year period of
colonial violence slavery Slaughter uh
which is essentially erasing that and
creating the framework for the
enlightenment to emerge you can't
separate that from that from that
knowledge program and unfortunately that
still is the program that we're run so
they still are the key thinkers that
embed our world and so when we think
about why global inequality hasn't
really changed it's still kind of the
same as it was 23 years ago it's that
ual framework is absolutely embedded in
it thinking about it in a more sort of
scholarly way do you think the only way
to understand these old text is to
really fully embarrass yourself in the
context of the time could we not just
pick up a book read it and make what we
make of it do we have to kind of
interpret it in its holistic context as
a well to really understand it yeah
there is no such thing as abstract
knowledge doesn't just come abstractly
knowledge is very much rooted into the
politics of the time what it's happening
at the time and so the it's a fantasy to
suggest that you could just pick up K
and read it and go oh this this is this
is nice we just take the bits we like
and leave the bits we don't like that
really isn't how how knowledge works I
don't
think how do you understand sort of your
relationship to the discipline of
philosophy and the history of ideas in
general since a lot of it is sort of
caught up in these problematic political
contexts of racism slavery huge
inequality how do we find any value as
it work and that traditional do we not
find any value do we have to make our
own tradition um it's interesting
because I I'm an academic right so I
work at a university but you know black
studies has a completely different
historical idea of knowledge so for
example Malcolm X is my absolute
favorite intellectual and I would
suggest you if you want to understand
the world you are far better off
listening to Malcolm X speeches than you
are listening reading the Manuel Kent
just just it's just a a better way of
understanding the world and so a lot of
my work is to challenge that and
actually to say why are we holding these
people esteem in esteem and I would have
said prior to W in the New Age of Empire
I probably would have said look it's
keep k whatever whatever but actually
you actually read the detail of it K's
not people like that they're not just
not the racism isn't incidental it's
actually baked into the ideas and you're
actually much better off not reading K I
didn't read K properly till I was my
late 30s I actually think I understand
the world better because of that so know
I would say let's challenge let's think
about other things why do we have to
Center knowledge through dead white men
all the time like it's there's lots of
other stuff to read and to engage in and
there's lots of other Traditions which
must be we be better off if we engage in
them what about thinkers like Martin
Luther King who's more and more kind of
thought of as a political philosopher
and his own right and you know he he
clearly found some kind of value in some
of the kind of Western texts you know
Hegel n people like that would kind of
pushing that aside make certain um forms
of thought unavailable to us if we just
refus to engage with that Cannon
wouldn't we be losing something well I
mean I think so I mean even like unless
not to say there's nothing good in the
western Cannon I mean Mark has some good
ideas Hegel certainly has some
problematic not not bad ideas there's
certainly stuff you can pick no one's
saying you just take all white
philosophy and and historians and throw
them and throw them out certainly not
saying that what we're saying is why do
we have to center it why does it have to
be why if you have to go through that
that's that's the problem not that you
can't engage and someone like Malcolm
Malcolm read everything Malcolm engages
all these things and interestingly the
founding documents the like the
organization afroamerican Unity which
Malcolm started as a project for black
radicalism you know cites the UN
Declaration of right CES the US
Constitution and takes those say this
say actually the words are quite good
right but actually can you make them
meet actually meet the how if you
actually want to live up to the US
Constitution you want to live up to un
Declaration of Rights then you have to
look differently because going through
each each even marks and all that is not
going to get you to the kind of libert
Liberty that we really want to move to a
different topic of your work you've used
the language of psychosis to describe
our current Collective State especially
that of white people what do you mean by
that how do we apply the language of
psychoanalysis onto social phenomena yes
so importantly this a metaphor I want to
stress not saying that all white people
are psychotic although actually people
haven't made the argument I'm not making
the argument as in a metaphor of think
about what is whiteness whiteness is a
set of ideas a way of understanding the
world um and really having engaged in
these debates for a very long time
there's nothing else to compare it to
the the the Lo there is no logic or
rationality to the discourse of
whiteness um you know people have spent
a lot of time with CR critical whiteness
studies been in the news recently things
like critical race Theory you know can
you kind of educate whiteness out and my
experience has always been no you can't
that it isn't about chat you know
bringing in new ideas and bringing in
new evidence and bringing in a fresh
perspective actually it's a completely
delusional irrational framework that no
matter what evidence you put in front of
it it will it will disintegrate and
become something else and you think
about what a cois does in in in mental
health it essentially tries to convince
you that you're okay right so you're
completely out of your mind and is
trying to convince you that you're okay
and this is what the psychosis of
whiteness does we have a political
economy which is based on the
exploitation of black and brown people
so that the white world can be can be
prosperous and by the white world I live
in the white world I benefit from the
white world you don't have to be white
to benefit from the white world and if
you think about the prosperity which I
have it depends on 9 million people
dying from hunger every year in the
third world it depends on a child dying
every 10 seconds cuz they haven't got
access to food
and so if we were to actually accept
that to accept that look we have nice
things and nice lives because people die
would obviously we' fall apart right so
the purpose of the psychosis is to
delude us into thinking that that's not
happening that it's okay and that's why
whiteness is impenetrable there's no
point in trying to educate it out the
only way to get rid of whiteness is to
change the economic system that produces
produces
it what do you make of the Queen's
Jubilee celebrations that are taking
place as we speak is that would that be
an example of a sort of
psychotic event in your in your view or
I mean what else could there be the
celebration of the the monarchy than
psychosis I mean there's no what do they
they don't have any real purpose or real
value they are simply a symbol of white
supremacy it's not a coincidence that
about roughly two-thirds of the
population uh support the monarchy and
over half of the population think the
British Empire was a good thing right
did positive things in the world those
things are very connected and what we
have with this with the monach and why
the queen so popular is cuz she presents
all of that right and people for and
celebrate over this this this Born To
Rule Elite that have no connection to
your life at all honestly there's no
there's no rational justification for
the monarchy yet millions of people in
this country will celebrate them if
there's a better example of psychosis of
whiteness I I don't think I don't I
can't think it
would if um if we take your sort of
diagnosis as it were um to be correct
that we are suffering from a kind of
collective psychosis is there a cure for
it like what do we do with that
diagnosis is it just
a sort of diagnosis of Despair or is
there a way to to kind of cure our
Collective illnesses yeah well you have
to deal with the with the illness and
not the symptoms and psychosis is often
a symptom rather than the illness itself
right like it's a thing which keeps you
keeps you stops you from realizing
you're ill and so the purpose I did this
cuz I I don't really I writing a book
about whiteness cuz I have a book
psychosis of whiteness coming out there
never something I was really that
interested in but then really started
thinking about it and actually it's it's
like a very radical idea cuz what I
saying is yes you can there's a problem
that can be fixed totally but you have
to fix the cause and the cause of the
psychosis is the economy it's the
economy and until you change that you're
not going to change the psychosis and
the point and a lot of the time I talk
about psychosis it is a challenge to
critical whitness studies which it's
become effectively a a cottage industry
there's now books like self-help books
that will teach out your white supremacy
teach out your white your white
privilege a of nonsense in fact that's
probably the the best example of psychos
you can find the idea that you could Pro
possibly just in a manual to teach out
somebody's White Privilege if we to say
right so my point here is that we can
get rid of we can deal with whiteness
but the ways that we're trying to do it
are actually feeding into the psychosis
more and more and more and actually what
we should be doing is saying we need to
change the politics and the economy in
short it's a revolutionary project but
that's the only way to get rid of Wess
so the problem with u with the usual
approaches to to racism that you just
pointed out is it a sort of misdiagnosis
of the problem then it's it's seeing it
as a kind of psychological problem a
kind of problem an individual but maybe
maybe even at a collective level but
something that can be so we can be
educated out of by reading books yeah if
you think about it like a lot of people
say they're saying it's not about
individuals but then the solution is
usually education and if your solution
is education then you are saying it's
about individuals individuals don't have
the correct don't have enough knowledge
they don't have enough foresight if you
can just teach people the right things
in schools and they're going to act
differently and they're going to change
the world that's not how it works it's
it's and this is again going back to
someone like the enlightenment
conversation it's not that Emanuel Ken
didn't know stuff he just knew stuff I
didn't care he just interpreted in a
particular way right um and that's what
happens all the time so when you put
forward the evidence it's not that
things will change just the conversation
changes right so the idea you can
educate whiteness out is is a complete
mistake we should be saying well
actually how do we how do we change the
economy so that it doesn't benefit white
people so it doesn't that's how you
that's how you get rid of ways you said
it's a radical project and I was
wondering like if it is a collective
action problem
at the moment the institutions we have
for redirecting that are things like
liberal democracy parliamentary
democracy um do you see those
institutions are as capable of treating
the problem or do you think we need new
institutions oh no 100% no the
institutions and this is other part of
the argument is this because psychosis
because the discourse is is essentially
psychotic right the the rationality
between institutions is you can't fix
these institutions like when people talk
about decolonizing University I never
say colonizing the university the
university is what it is it's not going
to change um there are things we can do
within the university differently but
ultimately it will take institutions
outside of the University or outside of
the schools or outside of the the
government Etc and if you go back 50
years you had revolutionary movements P
africanism even Marxism has become a
dirty word and I'm not a Marxist really
at all but you know you had third world
movements and you had say actually let's
do something differently why why are we
why are we stuck with this like the
British parliamentary system do no no
like it was the whole purpose of it and
not just on racial terms on class terms
I mean elite elite just on the elite
level by itself that's the purpose of
the institution so you have to do this
outside you cannot do it inside so how
do we go about creating as it were new
institutions that don't suffer from the
same original sins as things like
parliamentary or the British Parliament
as well I mean so far I mean this is so
my first second second book so my book
before the New Age of Empire was Back to
Black retelling that radicalism for 21st
century and that kind of puts a
blueprint at least for for Africa and
diasporas is actually look we don't one
of these things will be the nation state
I mean the nation states the
the the idea that there is a British
solution to this or a Jamaican solution
or a Gyan solution I mean that again is
entirely the problem like particularly
when you think about a nation like
Jamaica which my family only lived there
because of slavery it doesn't can't
really solve any of our problems and the
econom is just dire why why on Earth
would you contain your politics into
Jamaica it's a it's a that is again a
great example of psychosis it's just
going to go around and around and around
and around and so it's been a long
history of in Black organizations saying
actually no let's look differently the
nation isn't the nation you live the
nation is the nation the Black Nation
like a Marcus garvey's Universal negro
Improvement Association um you have
independent education so in the UK we
have things like Saturday schools and
and our own educational things outside
the school to teach different things
which actually where I know most of the
stuff I know so it's all there's a long
history of people saying no we'll just
create our own educational institutions
we'll create our own um National
framework even and eventually if you you
connect that and connect that and make
that bigger you don't need the nation
state you don't you don't need the West
I think that's a big thing for me would
be all of these problems are Global
problems in fact the thing that makes
the West the West is it it's Global that
actually Britain is relatively
irrelevant as a nation it is what
Britain does around the world in concept
with other people but we've kind of
focused our energies on the n on the
nation and that that that that can't
really work so we have to have Global
thinking Global ideas and Glo different
Global
institutions G Andrews thank you very
much thank
[Music]
you